what do you think about Ernest Becker
and those guys that put
death at the what is it the warm at the
core which uh as the main thing
the main create like this confrontation
of our own mortality first of all being
understandable more Mortal and then
confronting the terror of it the the
fear of it
as the creative like trying to escape
the fear of death as the creative force
of human society it's like the reason we
do anything is because we're just
running away from our death
scared
do you find
some of that to be true first of all as
a somebody who looks in the mirror looks
at yourself and your own as a human
being to just looking at society today
and three at this whole big spread of
human history and all the cool stuff
we've created including the mysteries of
eluses
I wonder what life would look like in
the absence of the fear of our mortality
I wonder how we'd interact with one
another if there was relatively little
or no fear of death I really do when it
comes to Becker's work and others if the
Ancients were known for anything it was
running to death
it was the opposite in fact dying before
dying which is the immortality Key by
the way it's not psychedelics when I
when I refer to this key I'm referring
to this notion that's preserved in
Greeks
if you die before you die you won't die
when you die
for some reason the Ancients prized that
experience and we talked about the
mystics of of Sufism and kabbalism and
Christian mysticism where you have this
the same self nodding this death before
death the Divine nothingness right for
some reason the Mystic Saints
Visionaries and ancient philosophers
they ran to death and the one message I
wanted to try and communicate with this
book is how they viewed life that it can
only be fully experienced fully embodied
in the wake of a really intense perhaps
terrifying but utterly transformational
encounter with death
so running to death not running away
from death